what's up guys I'm just chilling here at
this really high angle of attack it's
crazy how much lift These Wings produce
when we're up like this oh this is nuts
man Oh Betsy what's happening it's
almost like we lost a whole bunch of
lift all at once
[Music]
there welcome to pre pilot training I'm
Josh and this is Mike and this is
Private Pilot ground lesson 3 where I'm
going to explain stalls in detail as you
may remember from the last lesson lift
is good but sometimes we intentionally
want to reduce the amount of lift that
our airplane is producing one of those
times is when we're trying to descend
for a landing but something that's not
good is losing a bunch of lift all at
once when our airplane has a rapid loss
of lift this is what we call a stall to
completely understand stalls and why
they cause a rapid loss of lift we need
we need to take a closer look at the
cross-section of a wing this is what we
call an air foil up here at the front of
the air foil we call this the Leading
Edge then at the very back we call that
the trailing Edge in order to understand
this next part let's draw an imaginary
line from the Leading Edge of our wing
down through the trailing Edge and we
actually have a name for this imaginary
line it's called the cord line now as
the wing of our aircraft moves forward
through the air that creates air flow
over the wing in the opposite direction
as you may remember this wind is
partially caused by the aircraft's
forward movement it's also caused by
wind from the propeller which we call
prop wash and the actual wind can add or
take away from this total wind that goes
over our wings this total wind is what
we like to call relative wind and that's
what causes our wing to create lift now
when your airplane changes its direction
of travel like when it pitches up or
pitches down the relative wind changes
as well because relative wind directly
opposes the direction that your airplane
is traveling so you could say that the
relative wind wind acts on the air foil
at different angles and we call that
angle the angle of attack more
specifically the angle of attack is the
angle between the relative wind and the
wings chord line and this is super
important for you to understand now as
we just mentioned in the last video when
we increase the relative wind or when we
increase the angle of attack on our wing
we also increase the lift that our wing
produces as long as there's smooth air
flowing around the upper and lower
surfaces of the wing you may not know
this but but as air flows above and
below the wings it actually does so in
very thin layers because of that we call
this laminer air flow because I guess
the definition of the word laminer is
thin horizontal layers yep I guess that
name makes sense then but anyway at low
angles of attack the wind moving around
the wing flows smoothly and that allows
those little layers to stay separated
and flow around the wing in a nice
orderly fashion but as we increase the
angle of attack on our wing once again
this increases our lift because that air
on top of the wing has a further
distance to travel and that creates less
air pressure up there but if we start
increasing our angle of attack too much
that air doesn't want to flow around the
upper surface of the wing anymore it
wants to flow straight back and because
of that this air becomes separated from
the upper surface of the wing this is
what we call boundary layer separation
and as you can see from my pitiful
little drawing here the air On The Backs
side of this Wing is no longer flowing
in a nice orderly fashion it's kind of
just doing its own little thing back
there and it's just making a huge mess
so these nice neat little layers are not
nice and neat anymore and that means we
no longer have good laminer flow and
that's not neat at all how neat is that
now even at these high angles of attack
where we've got all this turbulence back
here our wings can still produce some
lift even though we don't have good
laminer flow and as long as the lift
that our wing is producing is greater
than or equal to the weight of our
aircraft we can just sit here and chill
at these high angles of attack with that
in mind if we continue continue to
increase the angle of attack on our wing
at some point the wing will no longer be
able to support the weight of the
aircraft and when that happens we'll get
a rapid loss of lift this rapid loss of
lift is what we're calling a stall now
something super important for you to
keep in mind is that every airplane has
a specific angle of attack that it
stalls at with that in mind altitude and
the gross weight of your aircraft can
have an effect on the air speed that
your airplane stalls at but the angle of
attack is always the same now right
before the air stalls it reaches the
point where the cord line on the air
foil is at the greatest angle with the
relative wind if this angle increases at
all Beyond this point the aircraft will
stall this maximum angle is what we call
the critical angle of attack and when
you exceed the critical angle of attack
on your airplane is when the airplane
will stall every single time if you
don't remember anything else from
today's lesson this is the one thing you
should remember when you exceed your
Wing's critical angle of attack the
airplane will stall
air speed does not matter now here's
something else you should know when you
exceed the airplane's critical angle of
attack and it stalls the wings are still
producing some lift if they weren't you
would literally fall to your death if
you stalled the
aircraft so our wings are still
producing some lift if that's true how
do you think we can fix a stall when we
exceed the critical angle of attack yeah
all we have to do is reduce the angle of
attack so to break the stall the most
important thing we can do is reduce our
angle of attack by pitching down or
releasing some of that back stick
pressure on the yolk this will get us
below our critical angle of attack so
the wings can start producing lift again
in just a minute we'll continue with
your training but would you allow me to
show you something that's specifically
made for Pilots that I think you're
going to like I've been flying a few
different types of airplanes now for
about 10 years and one of the things
I've noticed is that we Pilots tend to
accumulate a lot of equipment so I've
been looking for a product that I can
use to protect my gear and kind of
protect my investment so when Sterling
Pacific reached out to me and asked me
to check out one of their pieces of
luggage I was a little bit skeptical but
this luggage is specifically made for
Pilots so I really wanted to check it
out and I have to say this is exactly
what I was looking for I can throw all
my clothes and my gear in one bag and I
don't have to worry about it getting
damaged or someone breaking into it if
you do any traveling at all you probably
already know what I'm talking about I
don't know how many cheap luggage sets
I've bought but I do know that I've
spent enough money replacing equipment
and the old luggage that I could have
just bought something nice that was
going to last and the tough part is
knowing what to buy because there's a
bunch of stuff out there so if you're
looking for something with Superior
craftsmanship you're going to love this
product and if that interests you at all
you can get $300 off by coupon code free
pilot training thank you so much for
taking a look at this and let's continue
with the training accidental stalls are
some of the scar situations you can get
yourself into because of that you're
going to be practicing some of the
different stall recoveries when you
start your flight training you want to
see one check this out let's simulate
that we're coming in for a landing and
we get too slow and exceed our critical
angle of attack all right so I'm going
to get set up for a little power off
stall uh I'll show you guys how how I
like to do this all right we want to end
this maneuver no lower than 1500 ft AGL
2,800 is a good altitude to start out
we're only going to lose maybe a Max of
500 ft here all right so I'll pick a
heading southbound heading looks good
we're in the white Arc lower all the
flaps we'll keep this southbound heading
here all the flaps are in seat belts on
sctor valve on both makes your best
power throttle set we'll get the rest
here in just a second all right we'll go
ahead and turn the carb heat on idle
power pitch for 60 knots pitch it for 60
to simulate that we're Landing once we
hit our landing speed then we'll raise
that nose up on the on the horizon and
we'll just wait for the stall we want to
maintain our heading with
aerons there's the first indication got
Wing buffeting now now we're waiting for
the drop there it is Max relax carb heat
off first Notch your
flaps and then I'm gently bringing that
nose up to the Horizon broke the stall
by relaxing that back stick pressure
that's the most important part I've got
the nose on the horizon I've got to
climb so I'm going raise that second
Notch it's going to get rid of some of
the drag I'm waiting for 70 knots and a
posi ready to climb could probably pitch
down just a little
bit uh this part isn't really required
but this is the my procedure because
because this is a really systematic way
of raising the flaps slowly there it is
70 knots positive rate flaps up have to
take off checklist hey thanks for
watching guys I hope you learned
something from today's video in the next
one we're going to talk about how you
can potentially get yourself into a spin
and you thought stalls were scary I'll
put that video right here but if you
want to take a break from studying for a
little bit and you just want to enjoy
some fun flying get this video right
here a try I think you'll enjoy it
see
[Music]